MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for coming today.
I've got the pleasure of
introducing Mario Chamorro
today, who will teach
us how to make it happy
Let's hear it for Mario.
MARIO CHAMORRO:
What's up, Google?
I am Mario, and I am
here to make it happy.
It's not hard to
bring a charango,
to sneak a charango,
into Google campus.
It is not hard to
download a looping app.
What is hard is, is
to stand in front
of all of you playing an
instrument that I just
start learning to
play it yesterday,
and to download and use app
that I just downloaded on my way
to Mountain View.
Over the past four years I've
been working on happiness,
and if I have learned something
it's that happiness is hard.
Sometimes happiness is hard.
And sometimes happiness requires
one little extra effort.
One kind of like thing,
a breakout from you,
to take some action.
So this is how we're
going to start this talk.
When I got the invitation to
come to talk here at Google,
the first thing that I did
was to visit the bookstore.
And this is what I found.
Are you smart enough
to work at Google?
So my immediate thought
was, I don't know.
But I decided to
build up courage
to come today to share a
couple of stories with you.
So Nathan told me that I just
have 30 minutes today with you.
So the first thing
that I'll do is
I'm going to set
up an alarm that
goes on over only 35 minutes.
And my challenge is that
in less those 35 minutes,
I can share with
you one simple idea.
It's an idea that is
not hard to understand,
but sometimes it's really
difficult to embrace.
So how the journey
is going to go today.
It's going to go in
three different steps.
The first part is
I'm going to share
with you a couple
of stories, then
I'm going to tell you
about some of the work
that we have been doing
on the happiness field,
and lastly, I'm going to
share something with you that
happened just last week,
which is really cool.
The first story is about
how happiness brought me
to the Silicon Valley, and
to this peak here
with you today.
I am from Colombia.
I went to Columbia, and I used
to live on Columbus Avenue,
so it's really Colombian.
This is my volcano.
It's called Il Galletas.
I grew up in a city
called El Basto, which
is in the southwest of Colombia.
This is kind of
like the first image
that you see once
you open your window.
And it's kind of
like a magical place.
This is my dad.
That was this Christmas,
and he's 74 years old.
And that was the
very first time where
he start interacting
with Internet.
Surprisingly, yes, he was
fascinated about Google.
Not surprisingly, I will say.
So regardless of his skills
in computer and Internet,
I believe that my dad is
an amazing life hacker.
Why?
Because he always find a
way to convert something bad
into something good.
In fact, I'm going to share
with you one tip that he give me
what I was a little kid.
He told me that if I was able
to whistle any song that I loved
on my way to work or
to school, definitely
my day was going to be better.
So in El Basto I went
to school, and when
you go to school in a
little town in Colombia,
they tell you the biggest, the
largest that you can dream,
is to move to the
capital and to get
a job into a
multinational company.
Right?
But unfortunately,
that wasn't my case
because I got one of the worst
SAT scores in my high school.
And therefore when
that happened,
your professors, your
family, and friends
tell you that your future is
to take care of these ladies.
Right?
And as most as I love these
ladies-- they're cute, right?--
you have to see this.
These screens are amazing.
For the most that I
love these ladies,
I wanted to do
something different.
So when I was 16,
I moved to Bogota.
And in Bogota, I
remembered that I was just
staring upon all
those sky croppers.
Scrapers.
Again.
Again I did it again.
Skyscrapers.
I did it in college.
I'll tell you the story.
I was staring at
those big buildings,
and I remembered that
I was thinking why?
What's happening there.?
But back.
The country was in bad shape,
and the last part of the night
is the violence rate was going
up, the economy was going down.
So everybody was
telling, you know,
Mario, just go back to El Basto
and just take care of the cows.
Instead of doing that, I
fell in love with politics,
and I ended up working with
the president of my country.
That picture was when
we launched a loan
to support the
young entrepreneurs.
And life was going great.
And I was able to rent a nice
apartment, to have a car,
and everything was going well.
Until one day it was
my birthday number 24.
And I do remember
that when I woke up
and I said, well, how
can it be possible
that I haven't been able to
live in a different country?
How can it be possible that I
don't speak any other language?
I mean, I'm still trying, right?
So in less than three
months I quit my job,
I sold all my belongings,
and I moved to Boston.
In Boston, I just had money
there to be for three months,
so I was running out of money.
No languages skills and
almost not knowing anybody.
So I got myself into
a lot of odd jobs,
from salsa lessons to teaching
salsa lessons to valet parking.
And one day, I was
doing valet parking
in this coffee in
Newbury Street, which
is kind of like this
fancy street in Boston,
and I do remember that a
Ferrari came and parked outside.
And my reaction was-- I turned
to the guy who was next to me
and said, you know what?
My dream is not to
have one of those cars,
but my dream is to go to
a really awesome school
such as that guy.
And the guy was
wearing an MIT hoodie.
So the guy said,
well, you know what,
it happens that I'm a
professor at Harvard,
so if you want to come
and take my class,
you're more than welcome.
So I said yes.
So then I start visiting
Harvard, taking lessons,
and then I ended up
meeting a lot of people,
and then I fell in love
with all the academia
and with the energy world
and the finance world.
So then I decided I wanted
to apply into-- to study
at the ivy league school.
Everybody was telling me
that, Mario that's crazy,
you don't have money, you
barely speaking English.
Don't do it.
And until one day,
in this corner,
in Boston, it was this
December 24, 2004.
It was a cold night in Boston.
And I was parking cars
outside on the street,
then there was this car.
He came-- they had a
sticker on the back that
said Columbia University.
So I opened the door, and one
thing that I do very often
is I always share my
dreams with people.
Strangers.
So then I told
him, you know what?
My dream is to study
in that school.
And he say, well, you know what?
My daughter goes to
Columbia College,
but I don't think
you can make it.
So that day, I decided that I
was going to apply to Columbia.
And that night, in
that corner-- actually,
every time that I go to
Boston I stop in that corner,
and I just ask for three wishes.
I just did it a
month ago, actually
I wished that I wanted
to study at Columbia.
Right?
So, yes.
Four or five months later,
I was accepted to Columbia,
and I always have the
letter in my pocket.
And one night the same
guy came, in the same car,
and I thank him because
if he didn't tell me
that I wasn't able
to go to Columbia,
I will never take
the courage to apply.
So I thank him.
And it's how you
see these obstacles
and how you play
with these obstacles
and how awesome
things can happen.
So one of the main things
that I learned after Columbia
was that you don't need
to be rich in order
to be super-smart to
go whatever you want,
to do whatever you want, you
just need to put some effort.
After school, I ended up in the
finance world between Boston
and New York, working
from investment banking
to stock trading.
And then during the
financial crisis,
I ended up again with
zero money in my pockets
and starting my life again.
One day, I remembered that I
was in this magical place called
a Fung Wah, which is
a bus that take you
from New York to Boston.
I don't know if you're
familiar with it,
but I call it magical because
you have four to five hours
to think and it was
in that magical place
where my aha moment
came into reality.
My aha moment was this one.
I have two questions.
The first one,
what is your gift?
Everyone has a gift.
100% of human beings
are good to do anything.
To do something, right?
But just few people use
those gifts, and even fewer
use those gifts as
a way of living.
So then I start thinking
about this question.
The second one was a little
bit tougher because was
how are you using those gifts to
make the world a better place?
Somebody told me that I was
good connecting with people
and empowering them
with positive messages,
so then I decided just
to instigate and to start
taking into some experiments.
The first one was called
a tourist attitude.
Which is a kind of
travelers' attitude, which
is the state of mind that we
have when we visit new places,
right?
You become more curious,
you do more things.
You are here and now.
My hypothesis was that we can
activate that state of mind
any time in life.
And then I build a
website, and then
people from different
parts of the world
was-- we're using that
theory, and then I
get emails saying,
thanks for your idea.
I got a girlfriend I'm
enjoying more or my city.
And other things, too.
And thanks to that I started
doing more experiments.
Another one was called
a 365 challenges,
in which people used
to send me challenges.
And the challenges have
two characteristics.
The first one was the challenge
should be something to do good,
or to make people happy.
And-- it's OK.
And the second one
was that challenge
should be applied in
less than a month.
So my first challenge
was to became official
and to marry people, right?
So I became a priest.
In fact, I'm a certified
minister in case
that you guys need that service.
I can give you a good discount.
The other challenge
was to spend time
with the Hare Krishnas
in one winter day.
Another one was to give
out free subway rides.
Some people were really skeptic.
But anyways, It was
very interesting.
Another one was
called Nap4change,
in which I've been
collecting-- yay.
I've been collecting
pictures of people napping.
I hear here at Google you
have amazing nap rooms.
Hopefully I can get
into one of them.
But I've been collecting just
pictures of people napping.
Why?
Because it's better to take a
nap than to a drink a RedBull.
And the other experiment
was called happy post.
Can happen suppose we
start asking people
to write to draw
anything that makes
them happy on a Post-it note.
That little action is
spreading to 30 countries,
and then we have had three
teams 30 countries going
around stopping people in
the streets asking them,
what makes you happy?
And from that
little experiment we
start building
art installations,
and from those art installations
we start connecting people.
And from the
connecting people we
started learning
happiness what's
the tools to generate
positive social change so
when we with that
idea in my mind
I decided to push a little bit
forward, and go to my next gig.
The next gig.
So thanks to that, we were
invited to talk at Ted.
We have been very close
to the Tedx community.
We have the fortune
to having spoken
in different places in Tedx.
We have been also recognized
by the president of Columbia,
and also we have been creating
some art installations
and signing some happiness
agreements with some mayors.
Also, we got a lot
of media coverage
and when that
happen people start
getting more interested
in what you do?
Which shouldn't be like
that, but it is what it is.
So at that point, I decided
to quit my job again.
So I quit my
corporate job, and I
decided to start spending 100%
of my time doing happiness
initiatives.
So then I call a couple
of friends in Boston,
and then we build a
crowd-funding platform
and we launch it.
We work really hard
on it for six months,
and we launch it and guess what?
Nobody use it.
So at that point I ended up in
New York again with no money.
That's kind of like a
pattern in my life, right?
And then I thought that
probably some company
could support my ideas.
So luckily, by just knocking
doors and just sharing dreams,
I had this company
who believe in me,
and they gave me offices,
pay, salary, and Visa.
So then I was able
to have a place
to work and to focus my
attention on these initiatives.
But I'll get back to that later.
Now I'm going to
talk about this guy.
His name was John Paul.
He was five years old.
He's no longer with us.
He died already.
When I met him, he
was a cancer patient,
and the most amazing
thing about him
was that he was always smiling.
Always super-active
and here and there.
And his doctor told me that
John Paul used to tell him,
you know what, doc?
I'm going to die in five
months, but something
that really makes me happy
is to make others happy.
So he was giving dance
classes to his peers.
He was pranking other
patients, and basically he
was bringing a lot
of joy to people.
So for me, he was
a happiness rebel,
where I learned a lot from him.
So what rebels do?
Revels instigate.
Right?
And he became an icon for
what I'm doing right now.
So rebels instigate.
So what is instigation?
It could have a
negative connotation
but also could have a positive.
So instigating is to bring
about or to initiate an action
or event.
To change something.
So why instigate?
One example.
That's the O'Connor
exhibit in Sydney.
And apparently, in
Japan, something
is worth has been broken and
then you put it back together.
So they have this
exhibition with plates.
And my friend Freddie just built
this up, and he place it here.
And the people who were
working in that gallery
told him well, you know what?
That might fall.
And he say, well that's great.
Because if it fall, somebody
will put it back together
and will make it better.
So why instigate?
it's because you're able
to instigate also happiness
and to prank, happiness,
also, and do good actions,
then you can start
affecting peers
around you and probably
the world, right?
And that's the whole
experience of make it happy,
and this is the last
part of my story.
So this is where I am right now.
From the little town,
now I'm in New York,
in this platform where I
interact with the brand expert,
with product development
expert, with amazing designers,
with talented videographers
where they are supporting me
about taking these initiatives
into another level.
We are still in a very,
very, very early stage.
But this is something
that we have been doing.
So what are?
We are a movement of
optimistic rebels.
Optimistic rebels
such as John Paul.
As well as him we
have optimistic rebels
in thirty countries.
They are the ones who
do community organizing.
The ones who can
instigate more happiness
around their communities
and around themselves.
From art installations
to real-life gardening
to fixing something to
converting something
bad into something good.
They are kind of a
continuous inspiration
and this is the soul
of Make it Happy.
We believe in
happiness is a choice.
Everybody has a choice.
Happiness is a
human inspiration.
Otherwise somebody
can tell me that you
don't want to be happy,
you can raise your hand.
I hope nobody will
raise their hands.
Happiness is contagious.
We just saw it at the very
beginning of this talk.
We created a song together,
and happiness is a movement.
We believe also in collective
happiness Is not only
about your only
happiness, but it's about
how you have the gift of
how you can spread happiness
to those around you, and how
you can give the best that
is you to affect, in a positive
way, the community that
is surrounding you.
So we want to inspire people
to prioritize happiness.
For instance, you brush your
teeth every single morning,
right?
Why you don't also
prioritize your happiness
and think about things that
make you happy and just do it?
How we prioritize happiness
is by creating. tools
to instigate happiness, and
we do it in three levels.
The first one is in individuals.
So what I'm going to present
is little nuggets of things
that we have been
doing at each level.
Individuals, companies,
and governments.
The first one is individuals.
So we have been just going
to around building campus
ambassadors programs, regional
ambassadors, happiness
advocates, inspiring
individuals.
We have been also creating
tools such as this book where
we ask people, what is
your idea to make the world
a happier place?
Where we're trying to collect
a million of those ideas,
and hopefully it will become
an open source of ideas
of happiness accessible
to everybody.
Last week we launched
this campaign
with Mashable, in which we
asked Vine experts to send us
their video on what
happiness means to them.
And actually these were the
winners from this contest.
These were the main videos.
And we present these
videos at the UN.
So is kind of like you
just give a little platform
to participate and engage,
and something amazing
can start happening.
All those are vines.
Besides individuals, we
have been also working
with companies
creating partnerships.
We really want to create
partnerships with companies
to be able to
create these tools.
We have been also doing
workshops, lectures.
Columbia.
I'm from Colombia.
We have been doing a lot
amazing things in Colombia
where people and companies
have been signing happiness
agreements where CEOs commit
to really take responsibility
over the happiness
of their employees.
So this video was taken
in a bullet-proof clothing
company in Colombia.
We go there, we
work with people,
and sometimes you also
have to take some risks.
So I think I took a shot
there for happiness--
literally a shot.
The whole idea is that
they save lives right?
So they challenge me to also
to use one of their tools
with how they save lives.
I was chill.
It didn't hurt.
I swear In governments, this
has been very interesting.
In fact, a week ago, we were
celebrating International Day
of Happiness, and I'll go
through that in a little bit.
But we participate in the very
first that happiness summit
at the UN with ministers
from 65 different countries.
And when you see all got these
ministers discussing about hey,
we should include
happiness and this or that,
and how or how can
we include happiness
and the creation of policies?
That is when you start
feeling that there's
something happening, and
something in the air that
is somehow right about the
work that you are doing.
So we have been also been
working with governments
and we're big
supporters of Bhutan.
As you know, Bhutan,
I'll go there,
but Nima's going
to spend a little--
MALE SPEAKER 2: Bhutan
Ambassador, Gross National
Happiness, more important
than Gross National Product
because happiness is
about being human first.
We make public policies
that truly serve the public
by involving grassroots people
where every joys counts,
every voice counts,
every happiness counts.
We welcome you to this great
initiative by our friend Mario
Chamorro and Happy+ Team to
spread happiness for positive
social change.
MARIO CHAMORRO: So
the beauty of Bhutan
is that is that Bhutan
is this country that only
has 1 million inhabitants that
is between India and China,
and they started
taking the risk.
And it is to get in happiness
in the economy and just
really finding value
in a different way.
They measure all their
success based on happiness.
And thanks to the
experiment that they
have been doing that
there, some of those
have been replicated in
countries such as Germany,
France, and now--
more countries are
can just joining and joining.
In fact, in 2015, there's
going to be the new G8
meeting in Germany,
and Angela Merkel
is definitely very interested
on the happiness agenda,
so she wants to include
happiness as a new measurement
that countries can adopt and
build public policies from.
Also from the government side,
we have instigated happiness.
We have been talking
to different leaders
here in the US and other
organizations as well.
Just planting some seeds
about how can we support
and how can we breach--
I call this initiative
from governments to
the grassroots level.
This is another
tool that we build.
This is a great
story that I love.
So my good friend Navin
Masson, he's an MIT grad
and he lives in Cambridge.
And he was teaching this class
called art entrepreneurship.
So he went to the City
Council of Cambridge
to ask for some help
for his students
but the response was really
bad and really awful.
So somehow he called
me that night and said,
Mario response was awful.
I'm going to run for city
council and fix that.
And I say, well,
let's do it together.
And so we built this map
in less than four days
in which we collected
about 200 videos
and we place it on
the map of Cambridge
we geotagged everything.
And base it on the
responses about what
makes people happy
about Cambridge
and how they will be
happier to be in Cambridge,
he built his political program
and now he's a city councilor
and he's working some of
these initiatives as well.
So those are some of the tools
that we have been building.
And finally, this is
something that is very recent.
Just happened last week.
Beautiful thing about
International Day of Happiness.
The UN Created International
Day of Happiness.
This year was the second one.
So our vision is to create
an international holiday
where companies and governments
can celebrate happiness as well
as individuals.
It's a little steps, but it
can lead into bigger things.
It's just to show
the recognition
from the government's
side through happiness.
So we helped organize
this event at the UN,
and also we were able
to mobilize people
being in 18 different
countries where
we have different activations
from collections of garbage
in oceans to events
at universities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANWARUL KARIM CHOWDHURY: I'm
happy if my family is happy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 2: Happiness
everyone being human first.
Every child counts,
every voice counts.
Every happiness counts.
Respect happiness for
positive social change.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO CHAMORRO: We
wanted to leave you
with three words--
make it happen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what's really
inspiring to see,
18 cities people creating
their own initiatives
following some of
our initiatives.
We ask people to create a
happy face with their thumbs
in support of happiness.
We also asked them
to create circles.
But also they ended up doing
a bunch of amazing things.
And thanks to them we
were able to reach about,
like, 20 million people
just to celebrate happiness
to hear at least for the
first time about International
Day of Happiness.
And this is long-term
vision, but definitely we
want to get to a better level.
Mao Tse-Tung used to say
that revolutions are not
dinner parties, right?
Revolutions also
takes a lot of guts.
In fact,a good old friend of
mine used to say that it takes
balls to be happy, so
where does it start?
Revolutions start
with individuals.
As well as happiness.
Starts with you.
So everybody has the gift
to make the world happier.
Everybody has not only the gift,
but also the responsibility
to make the world happier.
From your own lives
to people that
are surrounding you, but
also in the amazing tools
that you guys build
on a daily basis.
And then this the
invitation to help
us to continue to
gain in happiness.
This tower is the largest
building in Colombia,
and thanks to my good friend,
Pablo, and to the Make
it Happy Columbia Team,
we were able to light up
the building-- the building that
I saw when I was 16 years old
and I was just staring at it.
That building was
radiating happiness,
was showing to the
city's 9 million people
messages of happiness.
So for me, that's hope.
And that's hope that we, all of
us, we can radiate happiness,
and things can happen, right?
So that's my invitation
for you today,
and that was the simple idea
I wanted to share with you.
Instigate happiness
from your own jobs.
From your own lives.
And help us to be
part of it like this.
Make a happy revolution.
And that's it.